so was habe ich noch nie erlebt in
meiner heimat ich bin da aufgewachsen
ich liebe meine heimat und ich habe
gestern abend zuletzt mit also mit
meiner familie gesprochen und konnte
doch noch jemand erreichen und die haben
alle gesagt ihr geht es drunter und
drüber und meine großeltern haben
gestern abend gesagt sie brauchen hilfe
von der feuerwehr
die sind jetzt wohl auf den dachboden
gegangen von denen habe ich aber leider
jetzt heute morgen nichts mehr gehört
meine eltern habe ich heute morgen nicht
erreicht meine geschwister nicht und
also mein bruder ist in köln da ist
eigentlich alles sicher aber eben in der
heimat gerne das ist zehn minuten von
arbeiter entfernen
alles überschwemmt und meinem vater habe
ich wollte nur erreicht weil ihr oben
auf dem berg noch fahren konnte bei
unser haus wo ich aufgewachsen bin auf
seine anhörung ist ziemlich weit weg von
dieser jetzt ja grade überflutet ist und
da konnte nur der also da war der keller
überstellt und er konnte jetzt auf den
berg warnte anfang zu haben aber fünf
minuten später habe ich niemand mehr
reicht weil das netz komplett weg ist
jetzt bekomme ich nach und nach
nachrichten von freunden die wohl
irgendwie nach nach internets haben
mein cousin berichtet mir dass die
wohnungen ziehen wollte jetzt so
überschwemmt ist dass er dahin ist auch
nicht einziehen kann
meine freundin hat bekannte die haben
vermisste die wissen nicht wo sie sind
und meine brust eltern also man eltern
bestimmt sie wissen nicht ob meine
großeltern noch leben weil sie haben
ihnen gesagt geht wird auf den dachboden
aber keiner hat mehr aus von denen
gehört ich weiß jetzt nur dass meine
eltern dass es ihm gut geht weil wir auf
dem berg wohnen aber da unten also und
da geht und die autos schwimmen durch
die also da sind autos die alle
gespräche videos also da habe ich
schwimme aufnahmen gesehen sagst du
weißt nicht ob deine großeltern noch
leben inga was für eine fürchterliche
situation in der du gerade bist du jetzt
sehen wir auch die fotos sie weder die
videos aus deiner heimat also dass damit
verbindet man ja seine familie sein
ganzes herz ganz oft wie geht es dir
damit wenn du das jetzt alles sie ist
diese zerstörung dieser ja so einzigen
idylle und wie hoffst du gehst so weiter
in den tag dann glaubst du dann kannst
du irgendwie kontakt bekommen zu deinen
großeltern
alles ist so ich habe jetzt schon
hundert mal versucht sie anzurufen da
kommt immer kein empfangen würde also
ziemlich zu erreichen
meine eltern können auch nicht zehn
durchgängen war irgendwie also hoch ist
das man irgendwo hinkommen kann und ich
habe heute morgen nicht gedacht das ist
ein horrorfilm also fühlt sich nicht
real an
und also ich hab ich das noch nie erlebt
es waren öfter mal natürlich regen und
natürlich überschwemmungen von der ars
ist immer ein bisschen gefährlich im
hebel soll im fluss zu wohnen aber so
hoch also meine großeltern gestern abend
gesagt das wasser ist fast im wohnzimmer
und das sind zwei etagen und die haben
richtig panik gekriegt und dann haben
meine eltern gesagt geht auf den
dachboden und wir hoffen dass sie es
jetzt gemacht haben weil es ist
natürlich die einzige lösung und von
meiner freundin die eltern sind in den
dritten stock gegangen weil da wird
schon das ganze wohnzimmer überflutet
war
und also mir geht es wirklich also ganz
komisch weil es ist einfach nicht
realistisch
und es ist auch ein ort der sehr sehr
idyllisch ist der auch ein tourismusort
ist und ich hab restaurants gesehen die
sind also da ist wirklich ein restaurant
das ist einfach ein gestürzt und ich
habe das auch hier glaube ich aber ich
weiß nicht ob ich es jetzt finde es ist
einfach komplett wie ein pub haus in
sich zusammengefallen
das sind bilder und da hatte ich noch
formal tonaufnahmen gesehen die halt
wirklich wunderschön anwalt in unserem
dorf bald ebenso viele touristen kommen
und es ist ein ganz idyllischer ort der
jetzt komplett zerstört ist und man kann
sich nicht vorstellen was die folgen
sein werden auch finanziell gesehen und
es gibt noch so viele van ist